So make sure you're standing comfortably.
And put energy into the spine.
Lift up through the top of the head.
Now bring your attention down your face.
Maintenant, mettez votre attention sur votre visage.
Donc, vos yeux se reposant sur le sol devant vous.
Les mâchoires relâchées.
S'il y a de la tension là, vous les remuez un peu.
Les lèvres ensemble, fermées, mais les dents séparées.
Les épaules détendues.
Si il y a de la tension là-bas, donnez-leur une bonne secousse.
Maintenant, portez votre attention sur la plante de vos pieds.
Est-ce que vous pouvez distinguer au moins deux types de sensations ?
Une, c'est la pression.
Une autre, c'est la température.
Et il y a aussi ces sensations subtiles qui nous disent que nous sommes debout sur un tapis ou bien sur du bois.
Il y a des parties du pied qu'on ne peut pas sentir ou qui sont des sensations très très subtiles.
Dans notre méditation, c'est très important de redécouvrir le corps.
Comment nous expérimentons le corps dans la réalité ?
Pouvons-nous reconnaître comment toutes les sensations changent perpétuellement ?
Est-ce que nous pouvons reconnaître que c'est ça que le corps fait ?
Il n'a pas besoin de nous.
C'est comme quand nous traversons une rue, nous ne pensons pas à nos jambes.
Donc maintenant, remontez à travers le corps.
Et regardez simplement ce que vous pouvez contacter là, à l'intérieur.
Soyez conscients des espaces ouverts, des espaces où il n'y a pas de sensations.
Quand vous arrivez à l'abdomen, pouvez-vous sentir la respiration ?
Ou peut-être que vous la sentez plus dans la zone de l'estomac.
Ou peut-être que vous avez une respiration timide, petite, juste dans la poitrine.
Vous sentez le battement du cœur ?
Les épaules toujours détendues.
Vous pouvez les bouger s'il y a besoin, si elles en ont besoin.
Les mâchoires toujours détendues.
Les mains rejointes, les dents séparées.
Quand vous arrivez au sommet de la tête, sentez les sensations sur le crâne, le cuir chevelu.
Maintenant, sans bouger les yeux, devenez conscient de ce qu'il y a à l'extérieur de vous.
Des formes et des couleurs.
Des bruits.
La présence d'autres personnes.
L'atmosphère de la pièce.
Mettez votre attention complètement à l'extérieur.
Au même moment, soyez conscient, devenez conscient de ce qu'il y a à l'intérieur.
A la fois à l'intérieur et à l'extérieur.
Une conscience globale.
C'est le monde dans lequel nous vivons actuellement.
Et sans cette conscience globale,
L'attention est attirée par-ci et puis par cela.
Par une chose et par une autre.
Et détendez-vous.
Simplement détendez-vous, se détendre dans le moment présent.
se détendant dans le moment présent complètement éveillé.
Dans ce mode, nous n'avons rien à achever.
Quand nous sommes dans le mode d'achever quelque chose, nous faisons toujours quelque chose maintenant pour des résultats futurs.
Quand nous sommes dans le mode de réaliser quelque chose, nous faisons toujours quelque chose maintenant pour un résultat plus tard.
Le fait d'être simplement ici, c'est ça le résultat.
Il n'y a aucune raison pour le fait d'être.
se détendant, habitant le moment présent, pleinement éveillé.
Dans ce mode, il n'y a pas de futur.
Il y a juste le moment présent pour toujours.
Donc nous n'avons pas besoin de planifier.
Donc, on n'a pas besoin de faire des plans, de planifier les choses.
On ne va nulle part, nous sommes déjà arrivés.
Se détendant, demeurant dans le moment présent, pleinement éveillé.
Dans ce mode, on fait que recevoir.
On ne répond pas, on ne réacte pas.
Donc dans ce sens, nous n'avons pas à présenter quelqu'un.
À être quelqu'un.
Demeurant dans le moment présent pleinement éveillé.
Ne réalisant rien, n'accomplissant rien, n'allant nulle part,
Il y a sept facteurs qui conduisent à la libération.
Ici, on en pratique cinq.
Cette conscience, cette attention, cette stabilité de l'attention, c'est une phrase que j'aime préférer à la concentration.
C'est une phrase que je préfère à concentration, stabilité de l'attention.
Le mot concentration, je pense, peut nous rendre un peu tendus.
Et l'énergie nécessaire au maintien de la stabilité, la solidité de l'attention.
le calme et la qualité d'équanimité.
C'est la qualité la plus importante dans les enseignements du Bouddha.
Cela signifie ne pas expérimenter rien
Cela veut dire ne rien expérimenter avec de l'aversion, de la peur ou des préjugés.
C'est une position sans préférence.
Avec un cœur complètement ouvert et un esprit complètement ouvert.
Quand ces facteurs sont développés, alors nous pouvons commencer à investiguer les enseignements du Bouddha.
C'est cette investigation qui conduit à la libération de nos illusions, de nos pensées erronées.
Cette façon d'être, vous pouvez l'emporter avec vous dans la vie quotidienne.
C'est si important de s'arrêter après chaque activité.
Après une conversation, après un téléphone, après un repas.
Just stop like this.
The importance of this is that when we're in this mode, we can see an intention arising.
L'important de cela, c'est que quand nous sommes dans cette modalité d'être, ce mode, nous pouvons voir l'intention arriver.
Dans les enseignements du Bouddha, tous nos conditionnements commencent avec une intention.
Si nous voyons qu'une intention n'est pas bénéfique, alors nous pouvons rester tranquilles et la laisser s'en aller.
De cette manière, nous déconditionnons les conditionnements non bénéfiques.
Et de la même manière, si nous voyons une intention qui est bénéfique, on peut la renforcer.
Juste de cette manière très simple, nous pouvons nous changer nous-mêmes.
Mais on a à être dans ce qu'elle a, dans ce niveau de conscience.
Notre prochaine intention sera de nous asseoir.
Donc vraiment, prenez votre temps.
Donc prenez vraiment votre temps.
Et soyez conscient de toutes les actions que cela nécessite.
Et rendez chaque action délibérée.
Intention de s'asseoir.
Merci.
Alors de manière idéale, vos genoux devraient être plus bas que votre hanche.
Si ce n'est pas le cas, vous allez avoir mal au dos.
Et si vous n'avez pas l'habitude de vous asseoir par terre, c'est bien mieux de s'asseoir sur une chaise.
Assurez-vous que votre colonne vertébrale a sa courbure naturelle.
Comme dans la posture debout, vous devez étirer par le haut de la tête.
C'est en fait la seule énergie dont vous avez besoin pour devenir complètement libéré.
Nous aurons simplement d'être assis ici pour une période très longue.
Les yeux doucement fermés,
Les yeux gentiment fermés.
Les mâchoires détendues.
Les lèvres ensemble, les dents séparées.
Les épaules détendues.
Certains d'entre vous ont déjà une technique établie.
Donc pour une retraite seulement d'un jour, c'est sans doute mieux de rester comme cela.
Ceux d'entre vous qui sont nouveaux, vous pouvez suivre ces instructions.
Apportez votre attention aux sensations causées par la respiration.
Dans ce type de méthode, nous préférons l'abdomen ou le ventre, le ventre dans le corps.
Dans cette méthode particulière, on préfère l'abdomen, l'estomac, la respiration dans le corps ou dans la poitrine.
Donc, il faut choisir
Et mettez votre attention simplement sur ces sensations causées par la respiration.
Et pour arrêter l'esprit qui pense
Je suis désolée.
Indestructible.
Et pour arrêter l'esprit qui pense, nous utilisons un simple mot.
Comme l'abdomen, au moment où l'abdomen ou la poitrine se soulève, nous disons « se soulever ».
Un petit mot, « lever », non ?
Et quand l'abdomen ou la poitrine s'abaisse, nous disons s'abaisser.
La notation a lieu en même temps que la respiration.
Ne le dites pas et puis après vous respirez.
Cela vous donnera l'impression de contrôler la respiration.
Laissez simplement le corps respirer.
Et portez votre attention gentiment sur les sensations causées par la respiration.
Donc c'est le vent, ça descend.
Si l'esprit vagabonde note ce qu'il est en train de faire.
Donc deux notations.
La première pour reconnaître et la deuxième pour reconnaître véritablement.
Worrying, worrying.
Thinking, thinking.
Planning, planning.
And then, just turn gently away and bring yourself back to the breath.
Et puis, détournez-vous gentiment de cela et revenez à la respiration.
Et quand vous revenez à la respiration, prenez la détermination de rester ici avec la respiration.
Le vent, ça descend.
Si l'esprit est vagabond, reconnaissez vraiment ce qu'il est en train de faire.
Pensez, pensez.
et puis ramenez votre attention gentiment à la respiration et prenez la détermination de rester là si vous commencez à vous sentir léthargique ou fatigué mettez de l'énergie dans la colonne vertébrale
Levez-vous à travers la tête.
Enfin, levez votre tête.
Vous pouvez ouvrir vos yeux légèrement ou même complètement pour laisser la lumière entrer.
Mais gardez l'attention à l'intérieur sur la respiration.
Et si la sensation de fatigue devient très lourde, alors vous pouvez vous lever et pratiquer de nouveau.
Le vent est très baissant.
Si l'esprit est en train de vagabonder, soyez patient.
Si vous jugez l'esprit, vous ne devriez pas faire cela, alors notez le jugement.
Et continuez à apporter l'attention de nouveau sur la respiration.
Si nous faisions cela pendant toute la séance, ce serait une bonne pratique.
Si nous nous sentons assis, fatigués, continuez à faire l'effort.
Nous nous sentons endormis, fatigués, continuons à faire l'effort.
Portant l'attention aux sentiments neutres, aux sensations neutres de la respiration.
Peut-être nous pouvons voir comment cela rend l'esprit silencieux.
Comment cela calme le cœur.
Apporte le calme et la mobilité au corps.
Bon, ça va être ça.
Si l'esprit vagabond, soyez rapide à en prendre note et à reconnaître ce qu'il est en train de faire.
Et continuez à ramener l'attention sur votre respiration.
Vous vous sentez fatigué ou endormi.
Continuez à faire l'effort.
Souvenez-vous que vous pouvez vous mettre debout.
J'espère que maintenant, vous vous sentez un peu plus stable dans votre attention.
Essayez de voir si vous pouvez vous rapprocher de la respiration.
Attrapez le tout début de l'inspiration et restez avec elle jusqu'à la fin.
Le tout début de l'expiration et restez avec jusqu'à la fin.
Donc maintenant, souvenez-vous pour le reste de cette période.
À chaque fois que l'esprit vagabonde, vous prenez note et vous reconnaissez vraiment ce qu'il est en train de faire et vous revenez à la respiration.
Et si vous vous sentez fatigué ou endormi, continuez à faire un pas.
Maintenant, nous pouvons ouvrir et observer quoi que ce soit qui vient dans cette conscience globale.
Mais il faut que ce soit quelque chose qui attire notre attention.
On ne va pas rechercher quoi que ce soit.
Donc nous sommes en train d'observer la respiration et puis peut-être que nous entendons quelque chose.
Toute notre attention va sur le fait d'entendre.
Nous ne sommes pas intéressés par ce qui est à l'origine du son.
Nous sommes intéressés par le processus d'entendre.
Ou peut-être qu'il y a une sensation dans le corps, plaisante ou non-plaisante.
Ou alors c'est peut-être une sensation dans le corps agréable ou désagréable.
Si cela attire mon attention, alors je quitte la respiration.
Et je mets toute mon attention sur ces sensations.
Et cela aide aussi de trouver un petit mot de notation, simplement pour que l'intellect soit content.
Douleur, douleur, souffrance, souffrance.
Douleur, avoir mal, avoir mal.
Cela peut être une sensation dans le corps agréable ou désagréable causée par l'esprit.
Une émotion.
Donc, si cela attire notre attention, nous y allons, nous laissons l'esprit.
Donc si cela capture notre attention, on y va et on quitte la respiration.
Et on le ressent de manière intime.
Sa texture.
On ne s'intéresse pas du tout à l'histoire.
Et quand ça s'en va, alors on retourne à la respiration.
Il se peut qu'une sensation dans le corps
Ou un ressenti dans le corps qui vient du cœur reste avec nous pendant toute la saison.
Parfois c'est comme ça.
Donc la respiration est seulement notre point de référence.
C'est ce à quoi nous allons contenir rien d'autre qui attire notre attention.
Et c'est l'endroit où nous développons cette équanimité.
Mais nous observons également la nature impermanente de la respiration.
Toujours commencer par la respiration.
Rising.
Falling.
C'est le vent.
C'est la médecine.
Comme nous expérimentons des expériences, des sensations, des ressentis agréables ou désagréables dans le corps, est-ce que nous pouvons avoir conscience de la manière dont nous y réagissons ?
Comment nous sommes attirés, comment nous souhaitons nous complaire dans ce qui est présent.
Comment nous souhaitons résister et ignorer ce qui est désagréable.
Soyez conscients de ces réactions.
Ne faites rien.
Just watch, observe, experience intimately.
Antibes.
Quoi que ce soit qui attire votre attention dans le champ de conscience,
Est-ce que nous pouvons voir que chacune des choses que nous expérimentons apparaît et disparaît ?
Rien ne dure.
Rien n'est fiable.
Quand nous sommes à ce niveau de conscience, nous ne nous interférons pas avec le corps, le cœur et l'esprit.
Nous ne faisons rien.
Nous faisons simplement ressentir, regarder, expérimenter ce qui attire notre attention.
Donc nous trouvons un poste d'observation à l'intérieur de nous-mêmes, comme ici.
Le corps offre ce qu'il souhaite offrir, quoi que ce soit.
Simplement des sensations.
Le cœur s'est ressenti.
C'est l'esprit qui veut toujours penser et imaginer.
Rien n'est directement sous notre contrôle.
Merci.
Mettant de côté toutes les instructions.
Just watch, feel, experience intimately.
Whatever draws the attention within the field of awareness.
Ne faites rien.
Quand nous arrivons à la fin d'une assise, c'est bon de réfléchir un petit moment.
Comment avons-nous été diligents pour nous ramener au moment présent ?
Si nous étions diligents, nous devrions nous féliciter.
Si nous avons été diligents, alors nous devrions nous congratuler.
Si nous aurions pu être plus diligents, alors nous devons nous encourager.
Comment avons-nous abordé les différents états physiques et mentaux qui ont érosé ?
Comment avons-nous géré les différents états physiques et mentaux qui sont apparus ?
Est-ce que nous avons été habiles ?
Est-ce que nous avons su quoi faire ?
Nous avons été habiles, alors congratulons-nous.
Si nous aurions pu être plus habiles, il faut que nous nous encouragions.
laquelle des trois caractéristiques a été la plus proéminente, la plus visible pour nous ?
Est-ce que cela a été le sens de l'impermanence ?
Ou est-ce que cela a été la manière dont nous réalisons aujourd'hui ?
Voulant, ne voulant pas.
Se complaisant, résistant.
C'est ce que le Bouddha nous a désigné comme étant les causes psychologiques de la souffrance.
Ou est-ce que c'était ce sens de pas de contrôle, pas de moi, pas moi ?
Et c'est bon de prendre une détermination.
Cela peut être quelque chose de spécifique.
La prochaine fois, même si je me sens seulement un peu fatigué, je me mettrai de nouveau.
Ou cela peut être très général.
Maintenir ce niveau de conscience.
Très bien.
Donc maintenant, nous allons pratiquer un peu de méditation marchée.
Ceux d'entre vous qui souhaitent avoir des instructions, restez ici.
Où faisons-nous le walk-in ?
Où ?
Peut-être dans le hall ou à l'extérieur.
Nous avons le walk-in pour nous, mais peut-être juste pour rester près du bâtiment.
On peut le faire, oui.
Pour la méditation marchée, il est possible de marcher dehors.
On a tout le parc à disposition.